lors de la première des six supérieurs à
Universal Studios, je promets au monde
que notre franchise, notre saga,
rentrerait enfin à la maison où tout a
commencé ici en Californie,
vous verrez pourquoi
dans le premier film, la guerre de course était beaucoup
plus petite certainement sous subvention mais sept
des films plus tard avec la taille que vous savez que cet
univers doit devenir je pense qu'il est
important que vous montriez non seulement la
croissance des personnages mais aussi la croissance du
monde qu'ils vivent aussi c'est 14 ans
d'histoire je sais que je n'aurai probablement
jamais de  franchise qui dure si
longtemps une génération entière ou deux de fans
qui apprécient vraiment ce que la
franchise a fait Je suis toujours resté en contact
avec VIN depuis la première partie et donc je
sais qu'ils se battaient pour que j'essaye de
revenir sur Hector ouais quoi de neuf mec
c'est une bénédiction que vous savez d'être de retour et d'
avoir un personnage dont on se souvenait tellement
Je suis comme Matt finalement ils ont
ramené Hector ou une
voix élevée me permet de montrer que j'aime vraiment les
filles dévouées élevées toniques et  une
cause cool et un arc de personnage et je
pense que c'était très important que vous fassiez
cette ligne de départ, ne vous souciez que d'une
chose que je sais